[Music]
while talking some more about me I am
the CEO of the Planetary Society and so
what I have encouraged the staff to do
is focus on our mission our mission is
exploring the planets to know the cosmos
and our place within it empowering
citizens of the world to be space
explorers so by focusing on your core
mission I think it will enable us to
work together to make the world better
now when it comes to NASA what we are
very hopeful is that we will acknowledge
that NASA is a fantastic envoi or it's
it's a fantastic brand for the United
States people everywhere no matter how
they feel about the United States
respect what NASA is able to accomplish
first of all and when it comes to
exploring Mars which is what we all want
to do everybody talks about all the time
well let's not have a reset let's not
cancel existing programs for the sake of
some imagined or proposed new program
wait let's finish the Space Launch
System let's finish Oh Ryan let's enable
the Falcon Heavy to be built and fly
this rocket from SpaceX if the United
Launch Alliance wants to build the
Vulcan let's enable that let's do
everything all at once in human
spaceflight and stay focused on getting
to Mars by setting a date one of my
favorite blues songs is set a date and
he's talking about I believe getting
married but if we set a date for when we
would be on Mars we're much more likely
to achieve it than to continually
suggest decades from now and as you may
know the Planetary Society did an
analysis that shows we could be in orbit
around Mars which would be analogous to
the Apollo 8 orbit of the moon in 2033
without changing anything about the NASA
budget just adjusting it for inflation
that's for one thing the other thing
that we at the Planetary Society very
much want NASA
stay focused on are these extraordinary
planetary missions we have Juno in orbit
around Jupiter
we have curiosity and opportunities
still roving on Mars we have many
spacecraft in orbit around Mars we have
New Horizons who is taking data are
still coming back from I guess it just
finished bringing data back from Pluto
and now it's on to the next destination
in deep space in 2019 keep those
missions going because that's where new
things happen where these innovations
happen in technology it's very a very
strong argument can be made that we
would not have this conversation
electronically on the internet without
the u.s. space program which led to the
development of the internet and so on so
acknowledge that NASA is a great
international brand as well as a source
of national pride and and technological
achievement and I will say to the fossil
fuel industries if you're out there
think about making your mission energy
production rather than fossil fuel
extraction and burning you know I
mentioned this to executives at Exxon
before it was Exxon Mobil many times
back in the 1990s when I was working
with you all that if you're an energy
company rather than a fossil fuel
extraction company you could be part of
the future instead of part of the past
everybody understand you no matter what
you may think about the energy needs of
the United States right now the future
is not going to be : oil it just is not
going to be it look at it this way other
countries are not going to buy products
made with fuel and oil with fossil fuels
in the future they're gonna put
essentially a tax on it a tariff and the
longer we stay the fossil fuel course
the more likely we are to run aground
there's a little nautical metaphor for
you but there's no there's just no
future in it I love you all but
no future so appreciate the space
programs place in the world both for
technological achievement and for
statesmanship and working together we
can provide renewable clean electricity
for everyone on earth if we just get to
work let's go
[Music]